[Applause]
and you hear the crowd
the whole favorite but does it really
matter if you make this five
we saw the entrepreneur
by the way jared allen one for ten from
three this year and maybe you see why
he'll stay like that okay there you go
oh yeah say it again shut him up shut
him up he win 31 he he win 31. that's a
special number see he's going to come
alive here he's going to come alive
nope jared allen's wearing a microphone
for us
he's keeping it come on there you go
look at he does have a smooth stroke get
about 10.
i i'm just going to call
[Music]
a
rage
point effort by jared allen i'm just
looking at my rookies on the bench right
now they're like right against these old
dudes come on
hey by the way this is ref cam
this is
inside the
jersey of our official that's right how
cool is that that's kind of dope red
they would have called all the openings
in his throw in jared allen's
they should have put a camera on his
throat
evan mobley next to play
[Applause]
making a running rookie in the year this
year
give
[Applause]
okay four-pointer
first miss no but he can't go back there
don't get your own rebound that's what
your your teammates are for one round
[Applause]
that is great i'm standing up for that
that's great
and now you have your best shooter last
in darris garland that was a smart
strategy here by the cavs
get the two big guys out first yep
get the weakest shooter out the way
first right right then the next best
shooter and now you're in with your best
shot so he's got to have a 14 to tie the
rookies right
that's right 32 on the board for the
rookies that's the number now this is
for the the first challenge 100 points
on the line here
and darius garland first time all-star
this year all he needs is 10 points to
get the 100 challenge points and that's
a great start
look how he's walking right that's
another thing
it's a put away punch right here
put away
[Applause]
hometown cooking just for fun here home
town cooking team cavs have 100 points
on the board and the challenge is
garland
filling it up another one from
five-point range boswell
[Applause]
[Music]
and it's all about the strategy though i
loved it let's get our big guys and our
weakest link out the way first it's
jared allen
and then maybe one of the the better
big shooters in mobe leagues but your
home run hitter
darius garland see different strategies
right giannis tried to be the one who
started off he was like yes i'm gonna
start the tone i'm gonna set the tone
right and it didn't work out they went
the opposite way
garland made three five pointers and
three
three porters
nice run they took one away but it's
still
21 officially and it is
the cavs
44 points they win the overall challenge
it's a